the company that prides itself on
shaking up wall street
is now part of it the mobile stock
trading app robinhood
unveiled its stock at 38 a share giving
it an initial value
of 32 billion the company offers mobile
users free access to buy and sell stocks
in their promotional videos they say
they are democratizing wall street for a
whole new generation
who were previously unable to trade we
built a mobile first
product that didn't charge commissions
or require
account minimums we didn't build
robinhood for the rich
or those with decades of experience we
built it for everyone
we're humbled to be serving over 22
million people
but critics say that can also be a bad
thing the gamification has become an
issue
because it's a little bit like using a
virtual credit card
it detaches you from what you're doing
right
so it detaches you from the serious
financial implications of the decisions
you make right
because we're used to getting a balloons
and confetti when we send each other a
text message
on our phones not when we make a
potentially substantive financial
decision
the company has had several
controversies over recent years
in june last year student alec kearns
committed suicide after thinking that he
owed more than
seven hundred thousand dollars on risky
investments through the app
his family later sued the company for
negligence in january of this year
thousands of customers were blocked from
buying game stop shares at the height of
its price surge
the company faces a class-action lawsuit
and in june this year
u.s financial regulators fined robin
hood a record 70 million dollars
for outages and exposing customers to
what they called
risky trading tools andrew moe is a data
scientist and host of a youtube channel
on the stock market
he and his subscribers have deserted
robin hood over those controversies
i think that robin hood has more
inexperienced traders and therefore as a
proportion
encourages riskier trading without the
full disclosure
of the responsibility when you have that
many inexperienced trainers
robin hood is facing increased scrutiny
from regulators and lawmakers
but with this debut on the nasdaq stock
exchange it will now have the money
to fight back patty culhane al jazeera
washington